il était pas plus beau restait un peu
vagabonds il n'avait jamais connu les
plâtres et les patrons il venait de
n'importe où aller au
88e dans sa roulotte vous êtes une mise
en place et le soir
je chante
les bretons
enfin
c'est vraiment cigna coutu a quitté son
filet
je blâme à une vraie
on se croit
s'il ne nous écoute mais pas épais le
petit jour la famille
allez sans paillage longo appelle le
temple
je vis il voit là mardi vont une
nouvelle fois
les ondes en chantant qui
j'ai vraiment voix fécamp d'aller où tu
vas
papa tu
l'été on se croit
m
une saison c'est ainsi que le garde
dessus l'horizon sans robben soleil
la semaine
je connais vous
les quelque part beaucoup de l'univers
je ne sais vraiment pas
m
t c'est moi